bonjour à toutes et à tous comment en
finir avec le béton qui grignote nos
paysages quand les Français se rêvent
tous propriétaires d'une maison
individuelle et que l'État fait face à
une crise du logement comment laisse
béton quand la France est championne
d'Europe des grandes surfaces et pas la
derrière en ce qui concerne
l'artificialisation des sols reffel dans
les années 70 Daphné euh un français en
moyenne vivait dans 25 m² aujourd'hui
c'est 40 m² de surface habitable par
personne conséquence beaucoup de
construction et évidemment et une
accélération de l'artificialisation des
sols l'étalement urbain augmente trois
fois plus vite que la population chaque
année c'est l'équivalent de la surface
de Marseille qui disparaît sous une
route un supermarché un parking ou une
zone pavillonnaire et enfin un paradoxe
pour finir la part grandissant de
logement vacant vide qui cohabite avec
le manque persistant de logement sur le
terrain en effet les élus se lente de la
désertification des centrre-villees mais
ce crispe dès qu'on leur parle de
sobriété foncière pourtant il il va
falloir lever le pied si l'on veut
protéger nos écosystèmes et lutter
contre l'étalement urbain et les
inondations car les sols stock du
carbone et retiennent l'eau ils agissent
donc sur et pour le climat l'état vise
le zan en 2050 non pas la célèbre
friandise à la régliss mais la zéro
artificialisation nette comment faire
pour que ça ne reste pas un vœu pieux
c'est toute la question au fait maman
j'ai arrêté
[Musique]
l'avion
alors comment concilier urgenence
écologique crise du logement vitalité
économique et épuisement des ressources
pour en parler Hélène Peskine architecte
urbaniste en chef de l'État et
secrétaire général du PUCA le plan
urbanisme construction et architecture à
vos côté Philippe biwix ingénieur
directeur général de l'AREP la plus
grande agence de maîtrise d'œuvre en
France sorte de laboratoire de
l'écoconception et auteur notamment de
la ville stationnaire et enfin Sylvain
massonau vice-président du pôle habitat
pour la Fédération française du bâtiment
et directeur de trad maison votre
entreprise familiale de construction
bonjour et bienvenue à vous trois avant
de vous laisser la parole
intéressons-nous à l'habitat la maison
individuelle avec jardin ce rêve de
propriétaire que la France promeut
depuis les années 60 serait-il un modèle
à déconstruire le BTP représente
aujourd'hui 25 % des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre il y a donc urgence à
changer de logiciel pourtant le rythme
des constructions ne baisse guerre
seulle la grogne monte le tout oppose
c'est un reportage d'Emma guizo et
Xavier
Louiset ang la ville où il fait le plus
bon vivre en France d'après de nombreux
palmarès et d'abord parce qu'il s'agit
d'une ville verte aux espaces naturels
nombreux comme dans le quartier des haut
de Saint-Aubin où une prairie de 6000 m
Carr donne au riverins comme Karine le
sentiment d'être à la
campagne je vais vous montrer la beauté
de ce parc au plein cœur danger regardez
ça et voilà le matin j'ai du silence là
on entend au loin les voitures c'est
normal on est quand même danger on est
quand même dans une ville mais on entend
en même temps les oiseaux tout le temps
quoi on
respire mais ce parc là est menacé un
projet de lotissement doit bientôt y
voir le jour 19 logements dont 10
maisons individuelles une zone de plus
promise à la bétonnisation euh quand je
suis venue ici clairement ce qui m'a
fait craquer c'est le parc où mes
enfants pouvait aller après l'école
avant l'école le weekend enfin moi j'ai
invité des amis en bas à faire des
parties de pétan où je jouer au basket
avec mon
fils clairement je ne pourrais pas
supporter de voir les arbres
tomber début octobre le permis de
construire a été accordé par la mairie
d'Angers Karine et d'autres riverins ont
fondé un collectif ce soir alors que le
conseil municipal se réunit ils ont
décidé de se mobiliser devant la mairie
vous êtes en juin oui et d'informer leur
concitoyens on se mobilise dans un des
quartiers des haut de saintauin on va
nous retirer un H de fraîcheur pour
construire des maisons je sa pas à
quelle heure ils vont venir les
a donc nous on veut on veut pas de béton
on ve on veut pas que les arbres soi
coupés on veut on veut que les enfants
d'école primaire puissent découvrir ce
que c'est que la faune ououp il y a
souvent un grand discours théorique sur
l'écologie comment préserver notre
planète et en fait dans rien dans nos
quartiers il se passe des trucs de
dingue les riverins interpellent une des
élus qui a voté pour ce projet Sophie
Fouchet Maillard pourtant membre de la
liste anger écologique et solidaire il y
avait pas le même météo et le même
climat il y a 30 ans que que maintenant
et conserver des arbres en tant de
canicule je pense que c'est priorité on
a un mer qui est resté dans le 20e siè
je crois alors il faut un petit peu de
de nuance c'est-à-dire que il y a des
gens qui ont on manque de logement donc
la question c'est où les Méton alors
faut-il bétonner ou pas comment faire
pour construire de nouveaux logements
sans polluer la France artificialise
chaque année 20 à 30000 hectares de
terrain l'équivalent de deux à trois
fois la ville de Paris le premier
facteur c'est la construction de
logement 68 % des sols artificialisés le
son pour l'habitat ce phénomène accélère
le réchauffement climatique nuit à la
biodiversité et perturbe le cycle de
l'eau mais le BTP emploie près de 2
millions de personnes dans notre pays et
les Français rêvent de maisons
individuell alors que les besoins en
logement augmentent alors peut-on
continuer de construire le modèle du PAV
P avillon est-il soutenable de visions
s'opposent Yannick ner est député de
liser et vice-président de la Région
auvergeronalpe Eloïse leier est
journaliste à reporter médiia dédié à
l'écologie ah bah il y a de gros besoins
effectivement de de construire des
logement par contre il faut aussi
accepter que tout le monde n'a pas
forcément envie de vivre dans une tour
dans une métropole le pavillon avec
jardin pour tous ceux qui en voudrai
c'est sûr que c'est impossible les
industriels qui tendent à continu à
vendre ce rêve bien sont en train de
tromper les
gens Ville du Bois dans lesones près de
Paris un petit village proprè de 17
maisons toutes neuvees coquette et
vide car en réalité personne n'habite
ici nous sommes à domexo un catalogue à
ciel ouvert le village des maisons à
essayer c'est ici que les Français
viennent toucher du Doig leur rêve comme
Miora et Christian le couple de jeunes
enfants et RAL bol de vivre dans un
appartement bon je vais vous présenter
un petit peu le pavillon entré donc là
on a une cuisine ouverte avec un plan de
travail un ot central en fait tout
l'espace ici fait à peu près 72 m² je
montr les chambres en haut et puis on se
mettra dans mon petit dans mon bureau
ici ils vont choisir le modèle de la
maison qu'ils vont faire construire à la
campagne je vous lais vous installer
c'est vrai que à la sortie de covid il y
a un très grandement pour les pavillons
effectivement le FA les appartements a
donné envie à beaucoup de personnes de
vouloir avoir un beau petit jardin pour
pouvoir faire du Barb Miora et Christian
sont conquis et prêt à signer 297000 €
pour avoir un F3 un petit bureau et un
petit jardin de 100 m car ben j'espère
réaliser leur ambition donc maintenant
on a un challenge demain c'est de
visiter le terrain à saint-chérant à
l'essue de cette visite madame va me
valider si environnement ok à 200% un
pavillon individuel c'est plus qu'un
simple habitat c'est un lieu à soi un
idéal directement apporté des
États-Unis né après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale dans l'esprit de 7 homme
William levit le roi des banlieux le
céréal promoteur des pavillons c'est lui
qui met en place ces zones
résidentielles
immenses partout dans le pays 38000
maisons ont été construites en
produite en masse elle ne coûte que
10000 dollars
chacune ces jeunes familles profitent
d'un morceau du rêve américain ces
dizaines de milliers de pavillons
signent l'avèement des classes moyennes
américaines c'est la belle vie en
banlieu un modèle qui modifie pour
toujours les
paysages la maison individuelle s'étale
toujours plus loin des centr-ville c'est
le règne du tout voiture avec ses routes
ses échangeurs et ses
rond-points ce modèle s'installe en
France dès la fin des années 60
encouragé par les pouvoirs publics le
pays doit devenir une nation de
propriétaire c'est près de 90 % des des
Français qui ont qui ont envie
effectivement d'être propriétaire de
leur logement c'est parce que vous
imaginez que la qualité de vie est
différente et est meilleure avec un peu
le rêve du pavillon de la Maison des
Enfants du chien comme la f fashion on
consomme du vêtement bah là on va
consommer du logement on va construire
construire construire faire croire un
peu ce rêve que la maison serait
accessible pour tous ce qui est bien sûr
impossible en terme d'espace ça
nécessiterait de détruire beaucoup trop
d'espace naturel or en France 10 % du
territoire est déjà bétonné contre moins
de 3 % au niveau européen et ça n'est
pas prêt de s'arrêter à Sens de Bretagne
un projet de lotissement menace un petit
bois aux arbre
centenairire j'ai trouvé une racine
l'artificialisation des sols détruit la
biodiversité car bétonner c'est
recouvrir la terre l'imperméabilisé et
porter atteinte à ses fonctions
biologiques alors le cèdre de la
classe ce jour-là le collectif arocaria
a décidé de nommer et montrer au grand
public tous les arbres qui vont être
détruits vas-y fais le
tour le but de ces petits panneaux c'est
vraiment de sensibiliser de révéler en
fait ce que contient ce parc parceen
fait
on peut pas dire que c'est que des
sapins quoi quand on a eu des premiers
échanges avec le lotisseur ils nous ont
dit bon oui il va falloir couper mais
bon c'est globalement que des sapins en
fait non il y a vraiment autre chose que
des sapins il y a une quarantaine
d'arbres il y a plein d'arbustes aussi
et donc c'est dommage en fait de de de
supprimer tout ça les arbres et les sols
stockent le CO2 tous ont leur utilité et
alimentent des écosystèmes vitaau pour
la biodiversité en plein
effondrement donc les ronds sont poussés
et au travers des ronces pousse les
jeunes arbres les jeunes qui se sont
ressemés donc vous voyez surgir des
noyés vous voyez surgir des petits
chaînes des petits châeners et cetera et
les ronces les protègent des prédateurs
ce qui fait que pendant jusqu'à ce
qu'ils aient assez de force pour
commencer à pousser et à devenir grand
toutes les espèces qui sont ici même
celles qu'on naime pas c'est-à-dire même
les ronces même les Ortis ont un rôle à
jouer dans la biodiversité toutes toutes
sans exception le terrain est privé les
travaux autorisés pourraient commencer à
n'importe quel moment mais le collectif
compte lancer des
recours au niveau national une loi a été
votée en juillet dernier pour essayer
d'enrayer cette bétonnisation galopante
c'est le zan pour zéro artificialisation
nette des terres naturelles et agricoles
un objectif imposé par la loi climat et
résilience de 2021 pendant 10 ans les
élus doivent diviser par par deux le
rythme d'artificialisation des terres
puis à partir de 2050 il ne leur sera
plus possible de consommer le moindre
hectare de terre sans en rendre
l'équivalent à la nature c'est l'idée de
compensation écologique quand vous devez
à faire des aménagements d'espace vous
pouvez enlever des arbres si vous en
replantez le double on peut
effectivement construire un endroit qui
n'était pas qui n'était pas construit
donc l'artificialiser si par ailleurs
dans un autre endroit finalement on
revégétalise ou de nouveau on rend
perméable ces surfaces cette idée qu'on
pourrait détruire et puis reconstruire
par ailleurs l'équivalent en terme de
qualité écologique c'est faux si vous
détruisez une forêt où il y a des arbres
depuis des décennies il y a toute une
vie qui s'est installée vous n'alz
jamais retrouver les mêmes qualités
écologiqu et cela prend vraiment
beaucoup de temps pour que la vie
revienne à nouveau pour beaucoup de
communes alors une seule solution
redensifier les centresville pour éviter
l'étalement
urbain je
P nous retournons à ang dans les haut de
Saint-Aubin où la destruction d'un parc
est contestée par les riverins mais
selon son promoteur et son architecte le
projet est vertueux voilà donc on est
sensiblement on est sensiblement par ici
en fait derrière vous mais sur la
longueurin il s'agit de densifier des
parcelles vacantes en ou dans les
villages des dents creuses selon les
termes des urbanistes une solution qui
permet d'éviter la consommation de zones
purement rurales ou agricole tout le
monde veut bien qu'on dansifie la ville
à condition que ça soit pas à côté de
chez soi c'est c'est un peu la règle et
on est très régulièrement soumis à ce
type de problème dans le principe duusan
on voit bien que l'idée c'est quand même
de construire la ville sur la ville et
plutôt que déétendre en dehors de la
collectivité ce qui génre des surcouts
des transports donc ça va dans le sens
du dans le sens de l'histoire de
construire à l'intérieur de la ville
construire en ville et sacrifier les
îlos de verdure ou bétonner à la
campagne le dilemme est de taille l'été
dernier Laurent vquier le président de
la Région auverg ronalpe a relancé le
débat en déclarant vouloir sortir de la
loi zan qu'il qualifie de ruralicide
destructrice pour les campagnes si on
veut que les commerces de proximité
perdure si on veut que les classes
scolaires puissent se maintenir il faut
quand même que certaines communes puisse
avoir un certain nombre de de logements
pour le renouvellement notamment de ces
populations sinon on va se retrouver
avec des territoires vieillissant sans
aucune apport de population nouvelle
avec une économie au point mort et plus
du tout aucun service mais bétonné
signifie-il vraiment développer les
zones
rurales en Loire Atlantique ça n'est pas
la vie de nombreux riverins de la
carrière du tin depuis 35 ans cette
carrière de gré est inexploitée la
nature a repris ses droits les arbres
ont repoussé et la carrière s'est
remplie
d'eau mais la préfecture a autorisé un
grand groupe de BTP à reprendre
l'activité pendant 15 ans plus de 2
millions de tonnes de granulas seront
extraits et des déchets inertes du
bâtiment seront enfouis dans les caves
de la
carrière ce jour-là différentes
associations et des centaines de
riverins se sont réunis pour manifester
leur
mécontentement nous nos gamins ils ont
appris à nager ici
et voilà c'est un lieu qui nous est cher
on n pas envie de voir 80 camions tous
les jours circuler dans les villages
pour ensuite venir enfouir des déchets
du bâtiment bah non ni ici mais ni
ailleurs en
fait les projets de construction
concernent essentiellement les villes de
Nant et Ren à 50 km de là qui viennent
ici sacaparis en fait des ressources ici
ils viennent en fait ensuite déposer des
des déchets on va recevoir les déchets
des villes en fait et donc la population
se sent elle-même aussi déchets quoi mis
au rebut de la même manière
[Musique]
qu la construction d'une maison
individuelle génère en moyenne une tonne
et demi de déchets et consomme 15 fois
plus d'espace au sol que l'habitat
collectif on ne peut pas envisager en
France des villages demain où tout
serait en collectif on ne pourra pas
remplacer un village de 300 habitants
par deux immeubles de 20 étag ce qu'il
faut aussi c'est changer les imaginaires
et peut-être que on peut rendre aussi
l'habitat en immeuble plus enviable et
justement en gardant des espaces verts
et en proposant des espaces qui sont
moins standardisés moins bétonnisé aussi
hein si le rythme d'artificialisation ne
ralentit pas 280000 hectares d'espace
naturels supplémentaire risque d'être
bétonné d'ici 2030 soit plus que la
superficie du Luxembourg
alors l'idéal de la maison avec jardin
est plébiscité par 75 % des Français à
l'heure de l'urgence climatique est-ce
que ce rêve pavillonnaire est comme
l'affirmaé l'ancienne ministre du
Logement manuel vargon un non sens
écologique je crois que d'abord le
pavillon la maison individuelle ça peut
être un rêve quand on est une jeune
famille quand la famille s'agrandit que
le l'appartement est plus assez grand et
puis un moment bah peut-être ce rêve va
se transformer en difficulté quand les
ados vont être grands ben on passe son
temps dans la voiture parce qu'on est
très dépendant de la voiture euh il y a
un moment peut-être on vieillit on a
plus envie de faire le jardin tous les
weekends t de la pelouse être loin du
kiné du bar des copains quand on prend
sa retraite et cetera R pour l'instant
plébicité quand même hein donc non
laaction c'est c'est effectivement de
dire de de quelle maison on parle et et
et et quel rêve aussi on introduit chez
nos concitoyens parce que il y a il y a
des envies à un moment peut-être de
métropole trépidante puis il y a
peut-être d'autres temps de de vie et
d'autres manières d'habiter y compris
dans des maisons on peut imaginer euh de
plus en plus des choses qui se
développent avec du du Béguinage par
exemple des gens qui vont décider de
vieillir ensemble de l'habitat
intergénérationnel des des des des
couples âgés qui vont accueillir un
jeune actif ou des communutés mais c'est
totalement marginal pour l'instant c'est
marginal mais c'est des choses qui
pourraient qui pourraient avoir vraiment
un intérêt parce que on lutterait contre
ce ce puissant levier qui est le enfin
un levier d'artificialisation et un
levier de demande de logement qui est la
décohabitation on est passé de de 3,1
par par foyer dans les années 60 à 2,2
2,1 aujourd'hui qui font que
effectivement même à popul constante
voire même la population légèrement
décroissante comme ça peut être le cas
par exemple en Allemagne et bien il y a
encore un puissant besoin de construire
ou d'accueillir et et donc on doit aller
chercher aussi et peut-être d'abord des
mécanismes de sobriété en allant
imaginer des mécanismes de
recohabitation alors c'est pas forcément
simple mais ce sont des possibilités
500000 nouveaux logements par an
seraient nécessaire pour éviter une
crise de logement majeur de l'offre en
France comment loger davantage
d'habitants sans étendre toujours les
plus les villes alors pour revenir un
petit peu à la réponse précédente en
fait on a des maisons individuelles
aujourd'hui sur le territoire français
en fait 30 % des Français à peu près un
peu plus habit dans des maisons
individuelles aujourd'hui donc elles
existent dans le stock et en fait on a
toujours cette idée que la maison
individuelle ce serait du flux c'est des
maisons en plus à construire demain
alors qu'en réalité on a aussi une
question de qui habite dans ses maisons
aujourd'hui et peut-être pas les
familles qui auraient intérêt et qui
aspirent légitimement à accéder à une
maison individuelle parce que les gens
ont effectivement des aspirations à
habiter dans un logement plus grand avec
un espace extérieur un moment donné de
leur vie notamment au moment de
construire leur famille disons-le comme
ça mais d'abord les familles ne durent
plus 20 30 40 ans comme elles ont pu
durer ces dernières décennies de plus en
plus on a besoin de deux maisons ou deux
logements pour une même famille avec
parfois deux chambres dans chacune des
maisons finalement peut-être que tout
est déjà là la question c'est
effectivement de valoriser l'existant ou
de le transformer non peut-être entre
1/3 et et 2/3 sont déjà là
malheureusement ils sont pas
nécessairrement là où les gens veulent
habiter aujourd'hui mais mais d'un point
de vue environnemental entre le modèle
le plus pertinent non en
urbanistiquement parlant c'est quoi
c'est c'est alors on comprend que ouis
on comprend que c'est pas la maison
individuelle mais est-ce que c'est pour
autant la ville ultradence et comme on
l'entendait dans le reportage des
bâtiments de de 20 étages est-ce que on
peut avoir une direction architecturale
qui serait la moins impactante en terme
environnemental alors ça fait un peu
débat il y a assez peu de de recherche
aujourd'hui en architecture sur sur le
sujet il a il y a quelques articles
scientifiques qui ont commencé à sortir
qui essayent de comparer les émissions
de CO2 sur un cycle de vie donc à la
fois les les matériaux euh enfin le CO2
l'énergie qui qui sont dans les
matériaux qu'on va utiliser et puis
ensuite sur sur la durée de vie de des
des quartiers de ville ou des bâtiments
et il semblerait qu'il y ait un un seuil
de contreproductivité disait le le le
fameux écrivain ivanelic dans les années
70 c'est-à-dire que oui le petit
collectif de quelques étages serait
serait plus efficace et quand on va
passer une certaine taille alors est-ce
que c'est 5 6 7 8 10 étages et bien là
enfin on va mettre en œuvre euh des
structures beaucoup plus euh puissantes
on va mettre on va avir des fondations
euh donc ça ça va la Fondation consomme
beaucoup de béton beaucoup d'acier et et
là effectivement on passe dans une gamme
où finalement ça va devenir beaucoup
moins intéressant du fait de de la
consommation de ressources et et donc on
est un peu rattrapé par la patrouille et
ça devient peut-être un petit peu moins
bien voilà c'est un peu cette idée là
donc la ville ultradense n'est pas
forcément la solution écologiquement par
voilà quand on arrive sur voilà dans des
métropoles où on se retrouve avec des
projets où on commence par construire je
sais pas 2 m d'épaisseur de béton pour
couvrir les voies ferroviaires puis
mettre des immeubles dessus pour bien
amortir le foncier on là on sent que il
y a effectivement une intensité en
énergie qui est peut-être pas très
rentable sur sur la durée vie mais ça
pose la question effectivement de
l'aménagement du territoire c'est ça la
vraie question parce que effectivement
on parle d'un stock en fait la ville dès
qu'on va parler de la ville c'est un
stock 90 % de la ville de 2050 elle est
déjà là c'est cellel qu'il faut
s'occuper c'est pas c'est pas juste du
neuf et de la transformation je juste un
chiffre si on voulait suivre la
stratégie nationale bacarbone qui est en
train d'être révisé mais telle qu'elle
est dans la loi aujourd'hui bien le
programme de rénovation thermique qu'il
faut mener sur le loge
sur les équipements publics sur les
bureaux il faut multiplier par 20 la
vitesse à laquelle on va aujourd'hui on
en a encore très loin je sais pas
comment on va faire ça avec quels moyens
organisationnel quel moyen humain quel
moyen financier mais c'est c'est ça
l'idée donc cette ville qui est déjà là
30 millions de logements à peu près de
résidence principal 3,6 millions de
résidences secondaires et de tourisme
pas que des longères normandes il y a
aussi plein de petits appartements de
ski et cetera et puis 3 millions de
logements vacants et effectivement ces 3
millions de logements vacants on sait
qu'il y en a au moins 1 million on
pourrait aller chercher qui est vacant
depuis plus de 2 ans et du vacant il y
en a même dans les zones tendues
aujourd'hui parce que bah ce sont des
formes urbaines qui plaisent moins voilà
on est en centre-eville on est moins
éclairé on n' pas la baie vitrée on n
pas effectivement potentiellement le
jardin la rénovation c'est compliqué
aller chez le banquier avec un projet de
rénovation c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
qu'avec un projet neuf parce que il y a
plus de risque tous les opérateurs
savent que on peut avoir des mauvaises
surprise donc on n' pas forcément son
alors justement est-ce que c'est moins
cher de construire que de réhabiliter si
au aujourd'hui c'est une certitude quand
on échange avec que ce soit des des
promoteurs privés ou des bailleurs
sociaux sur la la réhabilitation du parc
existant en ville ce que l'on constate
c'est que le coût de fabrication de
remise à niveau d'un logement ancien en
un logement dans les standards UF c'est
le prix du neuf à plus ou moins 20 %
mais là-dedans il y a quand même le coût
de l'acquisition du bâti initial donc
quand on additionne les deux on se
retrouve effectivement avec un prix de
sortie qui ne correspond pas au prix du
marché donc ça coûte plus cher de de de
rénover oui alors aussi parce que le
foncier urbain coûte plus cher que le
foncier péurbain donc en fait c'est
c'est surtout en fait l'équation elle
part surtout du niveau de prix du
foncier du sol pas tellement
nécessairement du bâtiment qui lui est
plutôt souvent une charge puisque
finalement il faut le réhabiliter et le
transformer la la question elle est
plutôt celle de à qui ça profite et à
qui ça ne profite pas c'est en fait les
bénéfices de la réhabilitation ils sont
collectifs c'est optimisation des
réseaux existants de la voiries des
ordis en ménagères des systèmes
d'infrastructure de d'énergie et cetera
ça profite au collectif à la
collectivité elle-même qui aura moins de
frais de fonctionnement en revanche le
évidemment le le le développement d'un
projet par un lotisseur en extension
urbaine aujourd'hui il profitent à
l'acheteur et par contre ça coûte à la
collectivité puisqu'il va falloir
étendre les réseaux deage des ordurement
il y a peut-être un enjeu précisément
des moyens mobilisés est-ce que il
faudrait pas lancer un plan Marchal de
la rénovation bah il est un peu engagé
on va dire ça comme ça en partie
d'ailleurs par cet objectif de zéro
artificialisation net en fait cet
objectif il avait d'abord pour vocation
de valoriser la biodiversité
c'est-à-dire c'éit stop à
l'artificialisation parce qu'on a besoin
de sauver la biodiversité et en fait ça
donne une indication aussi de ce qu'est
la valeur du sol le sol est vivant il a
des usages très différents qu'on soit en
ville d'ailleurs ou en dehors de la
ville qui peuvent être agricooles
forestiers vivriers mais aussi urbain au
sens social et donc à partir du moment
où on donne une valeur plus importante à
ce sol parce qu'il devient plus rare on
se pose la question de à quoi on veut le
vers quoi on veut l'orienter et pour
donner un exemple qui est un peu
contreintuitif nous on travaille
beaucoup sur des petites et moyen il a
une ville où justement il y a du du
logement vacant des cœurs de bourg qui
sont un peu désartés en fait le premier
levier de réinvestissement de ces de ces
cœurs de ville c'est la végétalisation
c'està-dire justement de donner du
confort de vie de de dédensifier parfois
des cœurs d'Ilos qui sont très anciens
ou qui ont été bâtis en fond de cours et
cetera pour redonner un peu de sol
vivant en ville vous s massono comment
est-ce que vous anticipez précisément la
mise en place progressive du zan prévu
par la loi je dirais là l'exercice
actuel de la crise économique est un bon
un bon exercice puisque on a moin 50 %
de vente dans le dans le logement neuf
qui correspond peu au prou l'objectif de
2030 qui nous est fixé par l'État donc
quelque part on va pouvoir tester
économiquement et socialement le
résultat de la mise en application à
échéance 2030 d'Usan donc c'est un bon
exercice on voit quand même que ça
chahute un peu les certitudes politiques
mais ça chahute aussi votre secteur
deement parce que la hausse des prix des
matières premières la frilosité des
banques exactement donc là ça ça nous
pousintérêt à la diversification on a
évoqué la rénovation qui est aujourd'hui
clairement dans le je dirais dans le
viseur de tous les acteurs de la
construction compris moi compris ça
devrait donc devenir votre cœur de
métier promoteur maison cœur ou en tout
cas une une activité certaine clairement
identifié et mobilisable économiquement
techniquement pour nos clients donc ça
on sait faire ce qu'on sait pas très
bien faire c'est maîtriser le prix de
sortie pour qu'il soit accessible donc
là là on recherche quels sont les
leviers sur le prix de sortie plus on
expérimente plus on affine les
diagnostics en amont et on est capable
de maîtriser les coups de sortie
puisquon on maîtrise les aléas je crois
que c'est très important de nous laisser
faire des expérience et là je pense que
l'État devrait encourager les
expériences et les encourager je suis
désolé mais fiscalement parce que il
faut de l'argent pour ça financière pour
orienter vers la rénovation plutôt que
la construction ou des TVA plus clair
quand franchement vous vous faites
aujourd'hui la rénovation l'ourde de
bâtiment entre la TVA 10 la TVA 20 c'est
vous grattez la tête bien souvent vous
finissez avec un redressement fiscal et
la TVA 20 partout et vous avez tout
mangé donc ça je crois que là-dessus
l'État se doit d'accompagner le
mouvement et de se montrer peut-être
généreux hein dans un premier temps mais
pour pousser des acteurs à être capable
de se lancer dans dans ces projets là ça
je pense que c'est indispensable et
l'autre gros levier dont on a pas trop
parlé dans le reportage et on a beaucoup
entendu la bétonnisation la bétonisation
bien sûr qu'on utilise du béton mais ce
béton là c'est une matière première
extrêmement chère extrêmement émérice de
carbone donc on essaie de la maîtriser
au mieux en la maîtrisant au mieux on
s'adosse à des partenaires qui
aujourd'hui sont des industriels qui
toussent des carbones très lourdement
soit la fabrication du clincire pour
faire le béton soit la fabrication des
produits industriels finis je pense
notamment au plancher les prémurs les
prédalles aujourd'hui tous les
industriels sortent des produits qui en
2 ans ont perdu 30 % de poids carbone 30
% on ne prend pas on ne prenait pas en
compte aussi la la carbonatation du du
béton he qui qui restock dans son cycle
de vie du béton à peu près 15 % durant
sa vie mais au moment où on va le
déconstruire et ça a été dit là dans le
reportage de la carrière quand on
fragmente le béton on augmente sa
surface et donc sa capacité à capter du
béton au moment où on déconstruit carb
pardon le carbone le béton va restocker
entre 50 et 60 % du carbone qu'il a émis
pendant sa production c'est colossal syv
mon vente les mérit du béton bacarbone
le béton vert c'est c'est un myth urbain
ou c'est une réalité alors la prise en
compte de la carbonatation pendant la
durée de vie oui on peut mais c'est
c'est c'est quand même pas ça vous fait
sourire quand même ouais c'est pas c'est
pas une grande quantité quand même par
rapport à ce qui va être émis nativement
dans une cimenterie quand on va
fabriquer le cliner qui est le composant
principal avec avec voilà quelques
quelques additifs du du du ciment si le
ciment venait dans quelques semaines à
la COP ouais 28 28 il serait 3è execo
avec l'acier au niveau mondial derrière
les États-Unis la Chine et les
États-Unis donc c'est c'est quand même
on émet malheureusement nativement du du
du CO2 et il y a pas tellement de
solution l'industrie nous propose la
capture du du du CO2 et le stockage
géologique je vais dire d'ici 2050 va
falloir se retrouer les manches pour que
ça fonctionne et queil y en ait
suffisamment et donc moi j'y crois qu'à
moitié 2 tiers des logements construits
dans dans le monde sont en béton béton
qui est responsable d'au moins 5 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre il
n'est pas inutile de se demander de quoi
eff fait le béton rfael Itier ça tombe
bien vous avez une réponse en béton
c'est l'heure de votre
climatoscope alors dans le monde la
plupart des constructions aujourd'hui se
font en béton qui est composé au 2/3 de
de sable conséquence l'humanité extrait
50 milliards de tonnes de sable et de
granula par an c'est on considère la
deuxième ressource la plus exploitée sur
la planète et c'est un phénomène qui
s'accélère et qui s'accélère très vite
juste pour avoir à titre indicatif ces
quatre dernières années la Chine a
consommé autant de sable que les
États-Unis en un siècle et que sait-on
de l'impact sur l'environnement du béton
bah c'est pas encore clair mais l'ONU en
septembre a tiré la sonnette d'alarme
sur le sujet la première chose à savoir
c'est que les ressources en sable sont
majoritairement inexploitables sur la
planète puisque ce sont d'abord les les
déserts et que ce sable est juste
impropre à la construction donc on ne
peut pas l'utiliser pourquoi alors parce
qu'il a été usé par le vent donc il est
plutôt Liss plutôt de petite tailles et
que pour qu'un béton soit soit solide il
faut quelque chose qui soit avec des
angles saillants ça ça pour que ça
s'agglomère correctement et que ça fasse
quelque chose qui qui est un peu de de
répondant en terme de de contrainte de
contrainte physique et donc du coup
personne n'utilise ce sable qui est
pourtant là à profuton just à titre
d'exemple le gras de ciel qui est le
plus haut du monde à Duba est en béton
évidemment mais est-ce que vous savez
d'où vient le sable qui a permis sa
construction non d'Australie en tout cas
le sable ne vient pas de du désert et
donc les gerboise et les fenêtres sont
donc épargnées c'est une bonne nouvelle
mais d'où vient le sable alors alors le
sable qu'on utilise vient des carrières
il vient des des plages du fond des lacs
du lit des rivières il vient de des
fonds marins des endroits où à priori il
y a de la vie et donc du coup un impact
potentiel sur l'environnement quand il y
a une exploitation parce qu'il faut
savoir que ce sont des systèmes de de de
raclage de de fond sa bleu qui embarque
un petit peu tout et quand il y a des
bestioles dedans que ce soit des plantes
des petits animaux des crustacés ou tout
ce que vous voulez tout ça est embarqué
avec au mieux s déplacé au pire c'est
détruit euh et puis même la faune et la
flore qui reste qui a été un peu épargné
par la la la la première vague est elle
aussi impactée puisque du coup il y a de
la turbilité qu'on appelle dans le dans
le milieu c'estàd que ça ça resuspend du
sédiment donc la photosynthèse ne ne se
fait pas bien et donc c'est toute la
chaîne alimentaire locale qui peut être
impacté par cette cette exploitation
alors à titre d'exemple tifqu ont étbli
un lien entre l'extraction du sable et
le déclin de la population des des
dauphins du Gange c'est un exemple il y
a eu le recul des prairies marines en
Indonésie ainsi que le le recul des
tortues terrestres en Malaisie enfin il
y a le grand boom de de l'Asie du
Sud-Est qui a eu beaucoup d'impact sur
sur
l'environnement l'extraction du sable a
aussi des conséquences en terme de
topographie c'est-à-dire que ça modifie
les courants ça modifie les profondeurs
enfin et donc ça tout ça vient mettre un
peu le chaos dans les habitats et ça a
aussi une incidence
plus plus large c'est que dans les
embouchures de fleuv qui sont exploitées
le sol descend l'eau de mer remonte donc
le sel diffuse dans les terres
adjacentes qui qui sont donc empoisonné
et quand c'est des terres agricoles
c'est un problème et on sait que c'est
le cas dans l'embouchure du Mekong qui a
don le dont le sol est descendu et c'est
une zone à grande de grande exploitation
agricole vous aviez conscience Sylvin
Masson de ces chiffres 50 milliards de
tonnes de sable et de granulas extraite
tous les ans est-ce que vous vous
recyclez comme d'autres entreprises le
béton alors déjà la loi avec la Rep nous
l'impose he donc on a l'obligation de
récupérer nos déchets mais au regarde ce
que je disais tout à l'heure du coût
aujourd'hui de nos matières premières on
a l'obligation de s'y intéresser mon
entreprise DEP 2007 elle est certifiée
nfhq donc Haute Qualité Environnementale
ça fait partie depuis 2007 on n' pas
attendu les les les récentes actualités
pour s'y mettre depuis 2007 on s'est
penché sur ce sujet-l et on s'est dit
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire de mieux ou
de différent qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
apporter parfois c'est modeste mais même
le modeste il est utile et c'est quel
est le modeste paradig je prendre des
exemples tout simples mais sur les les
laines que l'on vient mettre dans les
combles pour isoler initialement des des
laines
minérales aujourd'hui on fait beaucoup
avec de la laine de bois on a beaucoup
de d'isolants aujourd'hui qui sont issus
de la récupération industrielle que ce
soit des tissus des PVC et cetera bah
c'est peu en quantité sur l'impact total
d'un bâtiment mais c'est un bon début
pourquoi pas de du du du on parlait tout
à l'heure beaucoup de béton on utilise
assez peu de bois dans la construction
en France aux États-Unis c'est plutôt
beaucoup le cas qu'est-ce qui fait que
quelle est quelle est la contrainte quel
est l'inconvénient qui fait que on
l'utiliserait pas plus ce bois alors le
le bois historiquement la filère
française laa peu valorisé ou alors dans
du très haut de gamme on a on avait pas
de de très grossse production comme
l'ont eu les Allemands notamment sur des
des OSB des choses comme ça des panneaux
donc mais mais maintenant on l'intègre
il y il y a beaucoup par exemple dans
une maison ça c'est anecdotique mais
quand on a un carrelage on fait
historiquement des plaintes en en
carrelage maintenant nous
systématiquement on fait de la plainte
bois c'est peu mais à l'échelle de
300000 logements ça fait des quantités
importantes mais sur le bâti lui-même on
enviser et sur le bâti lui-même on fait
bien sûr alors moi je fais de la
construction bois partiellement pour
certaines de mes de certaines de mes
maisons on peut faire des planchers
intermédires des escaliers en bois et
cetera tout ce qu'on va pouvoir ajouter
sera du mieux ça sera pas 100 % pour
l'instant en tout cas pas pour mon
entreprise mais on y va tout doucement
les deux architectes que vous êtes par
quoi peut-on remplacer le béton alors
moi je voudrais rebondir ce que vous
disiez aux États-Unis enfin en Amérique
du Nord plus généralement la
construction bois est très très ancrée
pour une enfin très forte majorité des
maisons individuelles sont construites
en bois et maintenant même les petits
collectifs sont construits en bois dans
les zones où on commence à penser à la
densification y compris aux États-Unis
ça existe en Amérique du Sud c'est
plutôt la DOB et la terre qui a été
utilisée historiquement alors elle a été
remplacée progressivement notamment pour
les centres émergents les grandes villes
émergentes des pays du Sud par les tours
en béton mais les tours américaines du
début du siècle dernier elles étaient en
structure acier donc en fait on a su
faire autrement je pense qu'il y a une
question de d'imaginaire collectif
notamment dans les pays émergentss et
les les pays d'Asie en particulier
d'Asie du Sud-Est considèent que la tour
en béton c'est voilà c'est un peu
l'objet qui montre la modernité qui
montre l'accès à une certaine catégorie
de pays en en développement enfin ou
développé au contraire dans le monde
moderne et je pense qu'il y a aussi
beaucoup à travailler je le redis hein
ça paraît un peu anecdotique mais en
fait cette question de comment on
perçoit ce qui est vertueux pour plein
de raisons hein pour des raisons
d'attractivité économique autant que
pour des raisons de d'engagement
écologique ça joue beaucoup sur les
filières et leur capacité à se
structurer à trouver un modèle
économique viable et et des clients à un
niveau de marché suffisamment stable il
a une question aussi de coup de main
d'œuvre non utiliser le oui absolument
alors on utilise le bois en charpente
par exemple on utilise du bois en
menuiserie effectivement dans tout le
second œuvre mais quand on parle
effectivement des maisons on doit être à
peu près 10 % peut-être de part de
marché si on est en ossature et
structure bois et puis un petit peu en
dessous en petit
collectif il faut d'abord se dire que
oui ça ça intéresse tout le monde le
bois parce que c'est quelque chose qui
s'industrialise is bien et ça donc ça ça
plaît beaucoup au constructeur de dire
je vais jouer au Lego je vais plus vite
finalement que que de bétonner que de
maçonner et cetera donc comme à un
moment o il y a un peu de pénuriie de
main d'œuvre ça ça intéresse par contre
effectivement il y a des questions de
filière derrière et de capacité on va
pas multiplier par 10 parce qu'on sort
des forêt française on espérait jusqu'à
pas très longtemps avoir des forêts
françaises assez en forme avec beaucoup
de plantations des pains d'glace et
cetera qui datent des années 50 donc qui
donneent toutes leur puissance
aujourd'hui de de capture du CO2 et de
croissance patatra le changement
climatique les bioinvasions les maladies
les sécheresses font qu'on s'aperçoit
sans même parler des incendies que nos
forêts vont pas être si en forme que ça
sont d'ailleurs moins puit de carbone
que ce qu'on espérer dans la stratégie
nationale B carbone et cetera la terre
donc effectivement on peut aller
chercher tout un continuum en fait c'est
pas bois ou rien le bâtiment écolo c'est
pas juste un truc en bois avec des
panneaux solaires dessus non c'est bien
plus complexe que ça on peut faire
effectivement de la paille on peut faire
de la terre la terre crue en brique en
pisé en adobe il y a en fait des
proportions importantes de nos bâtiments
même des bâtiments qui montent à 3 4 5
étages comme à Lyon par exemple il y a
beaucoup de bâtiments qui sont
construits en pisé qu'est- qui limite
l'utilisation de de qui limite
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est plus
intensif en main d'œuvre donc ça c'est
déjà des compétences et ensuite il y a
le coup effectivement parce que et bien
il faut tasser la terre il faut
fabriquer les briques un peu à la main
et cetera enfin à la main j'exagère un
petit peu mais c'est beaucoup plus
difficile que des choses qui sortent des
industries et donc comme beaucoup de
sujets écolos en fait c'est comme
l'histoire de la réparation pourquoi
est-ce qu'on répare pas les aspirateurs
et ben ça va vous coûter plus cher mon
bon monsieur c'est la même chose en fait
euh donc il faut des aides et donc il
faut effectivement imaginer qu'on qu'on
fasse glisser quand même al de manière
progressive intelligente et et pilotter
pour que les industriels les acteurs des
filières et la visibilité puisse
investir et cetera mais il va falloir
glisser d'une fiscalité de la main
d'œuvre finalement la protection sociale
des centaines de milliards d'euros qui
sont assis sur le travail humain très
bien j'adore être protégé mais la
fiscalité écolo elle y a rien et il va
falloir basculer ça pour être capable
d'avoir des choses plus intensives en
travail humain un travail humain
intéressant aussi he quand vous discutez
avec des gens qui font de qui mettent en
œuvre de la teruss des sair vrais
savoirf des vrais savoir-fa historiques
ça c'est vraiment des des emplois de
qualité et demain qui seront aussi pour
la rénovation pas que pour le neuf et
être capable de de voilà de faire ça au
détriment finalement de ce qui est
intensif en en énergie alors justement
la transition est toute trouvée pour se
demander comment décarboner notre
habitat certains misent sur les
matériaux moins polluant et recyclable
comme le carton d'autant plus que le
carton est un bon isolant le monde de
demain commence aujourd'hui et
croyez-moi du moins on l'espère il va
cartonn comme le montre ce reportage
d'Emma guiso et
ibaraba la vraie croix un petit village
de Bretagne comme les autres ou presque
au milieu des maisons en béton une se
distingue celle de Nicolas ledirac qui a
trouvé la solution alors c'est par ICI
pour construire sa maison avec zéro
béton alors la maison est posée sur
pieux donc on est sur des pieux
métalliques vissé dans le sol donc ça va
être des pieux qui sont enfoncés à 4 m
de profondeur et c'est ce qui va venir
soutenir l'ensemble de la structure de
la maison donc en fait là on est sur une
un soutien de 15 tonnes par pieux grâce
à ces pieux la bâtise de Nicolas est
surélevé et empêche l'artificialisation
du sol l'au ruelle normalement et la
biodiversité est réserv si dans 100 ans
on décide de démonter la maison on peut
retirer les pieux réétaler la terre et
en fait le terrain il est comme si comme
on l'avait trouvé à l'achat quoi Nicolas
a construit lui-même sa maison de 138 m
caré à 39 ans il vient d'ouvrir sa
propre société de construction autrefois
installateur de maison en bois
aujourd'hui il utilise un autre matériau
pas comme les autres alors voyez si on
coupe la membrane qui faitt fiter à
l'eau hop voilà voilà on retrouve le
carton juste derrière c'est un carton
recyclé c'est un carton comme on trouve
partout les cartons d'emballage ainsi de
suite on est vraiment zéro
béton la maison de Nicolas est la 3e de
ce type en France il s'est fourni en
matériaux chez batipac l'entreprise
novatrice des maisons en
carton son président Alain marbuff vient
contrôler l'assemblage desuc mur en bois
et carton dans leur atelier de
saintnazer Sal tu vas bien bon ça y est
en préparation
d'un nouveau
mur on fait uneure primaire simplement
et puis on vient mettre les blocs qui
seront derrière le placop plate et
derrière le bardage c'est bien du carton
qui est à l'intérieur et que c'est grâce
aux alvéoles qu'il y a là qui contienent
de l'air un bon isolant thermique
phonique acoustique pour une mais de 70
m² il faudra 15 jours d'assemblage en
atelier puis 3 jours de chantier pour
que la maison en carton soit prête à
accueillir ses
habitant le bloc central qui constitue
le mur principal que l'on voit
ici derrière cela on a le par-epluie qui
protège le bloc le bardage avec sa lame
d'air et puis à l'intérieur le bloc de C
qui sert de par vapeur à l'intérieur de
la maison les rails de placau avec ici
du plau même si c'est un bout de bois
mais c'est du placau qui permet de
passer de l'électricité l'eau tout ce
qui peut y avoir dans une maison mais
ces maisons en carton ne risque--elle
pas de s'envoler au premier coup de vent
en fin de compte ce produit là il a des
vraies propriétés mécaniques sur le fait
que bah l'eau bien sû ne traverse pas
mais il est mécaniquement aussi
résistant actuellement ils sont en train
de construire à Brest un ensemble de six
maisons en bande et et ces ensembles de
bâtiments ont subi la tempête enfin les
deux tempêtes là que nous avons eu bah
les bâtiments ils sont debout quoi il se
passe
[Musique]
rien comme le béton le carton est solide
et étanche mais il est en plus
respectueux de l'environnement
aujourd'hui le carton qui est issu du
recyclage il est recyclable neu fois sur
lui-même sans apport de matière neuve
donc ça veut dire que quand je prends ce
petit bloc de carton que je le recycle
et bien je peux le faire ne fois sans
aller chercher un arbre ni d'ailleurs
d'autres matières si vous faites une
maison allez on va dire qu'elle tient 80
ans et que tous les 80 ans on la recycle
bah vous êtes quasiment sur un
millénaire sans avoir été prendre de la
ressource c'est ce qu'on appelle du
développement durable soutenable btipac
compte déjà une centaine de réalisations
en France à environ 2000 € le mètre
carré les prix sont proche de ceux d'un
pavillon traditionnel mais les économies
se font surtout dans la
durée retour dans le morbillant dans la
maison de Nicolas son isolation en
carton lui permet de dépenser moins de
100 € de chauffage chaque année là en ce
moment on est sur une température qui
est de 20°r dans la maison voilà ça fait
on va dire une quinzaine de jours que le
poil se n'est pas mis en route encore le
poil s'est mis en route une
fois pendant 1 heure juste pour vraiment
rehausser la température parce qu'on
était descendu en dessous de 18 tout
simplement parce qu'en fait on nait pas
eu de soleil pendant au moins une
semaine et demi la maison est douillette
charmante et Nicolas est intarissable
sur ses qualité grâce au carton ici on a
aussi une propriété acoustique et qui
est très intéressante parce qu'on fait
une réduction de 44 dbel des bruits
aériens chose que par exemple sur une
maison traditionnelle on est plutôt de
l'ordre de 25 dcibel donc on est sur une
performance acoustique qui fait que on
se retrouve vraiment dans un cocon une
fois qu'on est dans la maison quoi si
maisons comme celle de Nicolas verront
le jour à Brest en avril
2024 un matériau recyclable jusqu'à
cette fois qui ne se consume pas plus
vite qu'un autre voici une architecture
frugale et durable de quoi démentir la
FME de trois petits cochons ça vous
inspire c'est maonau oui oui bien sûr
tout ça c'est nécessaire toutes les
expériences sont bonnes à prendre et il
va falloir laisser leur chance à chacune
regarder quels sont les niveaux de
maturation et puis après de capacité à
massifier parce que la grande difficulté
ça va être celle-là sans maison c'est un
bon début il faut encourager ça parler
de 500000 logements il va falloir les
faire derrière avant pour être un
grandmire il fallait avoir une grande
ville cette philosophie est-elle peu à
peu en train de changer dans le sud en
raison de la sécheresse il y a certains
maires qui refusent maintenant de
délivrer des permis de constru ils ont
raison oui alors moi je le vois dans
plus que dans le sud hein je le vois
dans beaucoup de régions aujourd'hui en
fait c'est effectivement leseffit des
des deux derniers étés avec des
sécheresses très très marquées y compris
dans le nord-est dans pas mal de régions
de France les élux ont réalisé qu'en
fait leur rêve de développement était un
peu limité tout simplement par l'accès à
l'eau et bien souvent par un un accès à
l'eau qui est en fait assez complexe
pour eux alors dans les régions du
sud-est effectivement parce que c'est
déjà très occupé donc c'est un peu déjà
le conflit de l'eau mais dans les
régions très agricooles il y a d'autres
formes de conflit de l'eau on le voit du
côté de du Grand Ouest finalement on a
beaucoup de difficultés à accepter de
toute façon de nouveaux habitants et de
nouveaux usages et donc ça commence à
être un effectivement un révélateur un
choc un peu de de de de de constatation
de ces différentes pénuerie je pense
qu'on en est pas là pour le sable mais
on finira aussi par la rencontrer cette
peénuerie en en terme de matière
première et et on a fait nous un
exercice justement avec un certain
nombre de villes moyennes qui ont perdu
de la population ces dernières années
notamment dans l'agglomération des
Pernet pour savoir si réellement le
développement urbain tel qu'il avait été
réalisé donc en l'occurrence est promu
sur un village d'à peu près 5 ou 6000
habitants le maire nous explique qu'il a
fait quatre lotissements en 20 ans et
qu'il a perdu 1000 habitants donc en
fait il y a aussi à à déconstruire un
peu l'idée reçue que faire plus de
logement ça ferait venir plus de gens
pour autant on comprend très bien les
aspirations a augmenté de deux ou trois
familles le voilà la population du
village pour ne pas fermer une classe
dans une école et cetera enfin il y a
toute enfin c'est très objectif hein la
manière dont aujourd'hui les élus
décident de de de construire ce qu'il
faut c'est plutôt penser produire du
logement que construire du logement et
c'est là qu'on revient à l'idée que il y
a déjà un stock et que le déjà là est
susceptible d'accueillir aussi les
besoins qui qui sont ceux de du
territoire au nom de la défense de la
ruralité les élus on on l'a entendu dont
le président de la Région gne Ronal
pluren voquier refuse de mettre en œuvre
cette poliétique de sobriété foncière
qu'auriez-vous envie de lui dire l'un et
l'autre
Philippe moi j'espère j'aurais le
plaisir de le rencontrer pour lui en
parler effectivement moi ce que j'aurais
envie de dire d'abord c'est que ce zéro
artificielisation net il a euh il
rencontre un écho qui est qui est qui
est assez positif c'est c'est pas juste
c'est pas juste négatif il y a une vraie
prise de conscience de cette question de
alors c'est pas juste pour la
biodiversité tout ça hein c'est aussi
pour notre résilience alimentaire on a
vécu pendant 405 s avec des rendements
agricoles qui augmentaient et donc
c'était pas très grave en fait he il y
avait des friches et puis on
transformait ça et donc il faut sortir
de ça et ça aujourd'hui il y a une vraie
compréhension de ça les villes elles
peuvent pas avoir vocation à croître et
à se développer éternellement un moment
ça ne fonctionne pas au rythme où on
artificialise aujourd'hui dans 5 à 6
siècles l'ensemble des terres agricoles
on parlait de 1000 an dans le reportage
on va s'arrêter à la moitié l'ensemble
des terres agricole serait couverte de
de rond-point de de de parking de
supermarché ça ça peut pas fonctionner
comme ça donc effectivement faut aller
che chch une logique où les mares
bâtisseurs on verra en 2026 mais déjà en
2020 il y a quelques maires bâtisseurs
qui sont fait sortir dans quelques dans
quelques endroits et donc il y a cette
logique de dire maisain non les Maes
aujourd'hui ça doit être des gens qui
doivent embellir réparer transformer
adapter les villes aussi aux enjeux
climatique de demain vous entendez ça
syvain massonau oui oui tout à fait
qu'aureez-vous envie de dire à un client
potentiel qui a envie de sa maison
individuelle et et et et à Monsieur à
mon président de région et à Monsieur
vquier à votre président de Région
qu'ave
Monsieur B je pense que il il a eu cette
formule choc pour
euh imposer à la classe politique de se
réintéresser au sujet alors il faut lu
reconnaître qu'il a donné une publicité
invraisemblable à ce texte qui n'aurait
certainement pas connu autrement pén je
pense que la Genèse a été un petit peu
rapide un peu dogmatique et que le le
coup d'éclat de Monsieur monsieur vet a
surtout vocation à remettre les pieds
sur terre il a envie de montrer qu'il y
a un vrai sujet et dans ce vrai sujet
quand on rentre dans la technique
opérationnelle de la du zan il y a quand
même quelques sujets de je vais prendre
un exemple tout simple quand on prend un
terrain à construire 1000 m² c'est c'est
déjà beaucoup plus que ce peut payer
tous les gens aujourd'hui on est plutôt
sur 350 400 m² mais imaginons-le pour le
calcul à 1000 m² on met une maison de
100 m² dessus on a artificialisé les
1000 m² il y a aujourd'hui des gens dans
des villages qui ne comprennent pas
qu'on leur dise que leur terrain est
artificialisé ils ne comprennent pas que
la biodiversité qu'ils apportent dans un
jardin de maison soit pire que le champ
de céréales en monoculture intensive ils
arrivent pas comprendre et aujourd'hui
je pense que monsieur vquier se fait le
porte-parole de cette vexation là moi
j'aimerais qu'on on jette un coup d'œil
dans le rétro si vous le voulez bien
comme chaque moi Charlot tpal est allé
fouiller dans les archives de Lina et
nous a exhumé ceci hier encore c'est
notre coup d'œil dans le rétro et c'est
maintenant je vous propose maintenant de
suivre Jérôme bony dans les gorges de la
Loire le long de ce magnifique massif
Pila pour suivre son reportage consacré
à un lotissement qui pourrait bien
défigurer cet endroit merveilleux
oui Noël et vous allez voir qu'en fait
le pire est déjà fait mais je vous
laisse d'abord admirer ces gorges de la
Loire lieu de promenade privilégiée des
Stéphanois et bien c'est ce site que
l'ancienne municipalité de Saint-Étienne
a choisi pour établir une zone
d'aménagement concerté à 15 km de la
ville et ce juste avant 75 c'est-à-dire
sans ét d'impact les promoteurs sont
arrivés et c'est comme par hasard le
site le plus visible qui a été construit
en premier et la commission desciite
dir-vous elle ne s'était pas réunie
pendant 3
ans seulement peut-être l'hiver
sera-t-il rude pour ces accédents à la
propriété sur ce plateau très exposé au
vent il est même écrit dans le permis de
construire qu'il faudra prévoir des tas
de sables dans les voies pour le verglas
et puis il est d'ors et déjà évident que
ce hameau est bien
isolé c'est votre résidence principale
et où pensez-vous faire vos courses par
exemple oh ben avec les voitures et a
les supermarché puis il y a le village
qui est quand même pas terriblement loin
alors pour faire les courses chacun la
voiture cette opération avait été lancée
par l'ancienne municipalité de
Saint-Étienne mais la nouvelle
était-elle vraiment obligé de la
concrétiser il était aberrant de vouloir
urbaniser ces plateaux au-dessus des
gorges de la Loire mais il est dommage
également sur le plan du site lui-même
que vous ayez malgré tout laissé
construire sur l'endroit qui est le plus
visible qu quand on admire justement ces
gorges de la Loire euh l'endroit qui est
le plus visible je ne vous suivrai quand
même pas totalement sur ce point c'est
l'ensemble des abords du hameau de
kandamine qui est visible euh de l'autre
côté des des gorges de de la loi enfin
vous recnaissez quetisement est
particulièrement dommageable pour ah
mais j'en suis tout à fait d'accord avec
avec vous mais en matière d'urbanisme il
y a des coups partis que l'on peut
regretter mais qui sont malheureusement
comme on le dit dans ce jargon des coup
partis effectivement la Ville de
Saint-Étienne avait déjà investi 10
millions de francs pour l'aduction d'eau
et d'électricité sur ce plateau et
finalement la nouvelle municipalité en
bradant ce terrain viabilisé à phenniix
pour 30 francs le mètre carré aura au
moins contribué à offrir à des revenus
moyens une vue exceptionnelle alors en
effet 30 francs le mètre carré voilà un
bel exemple d'étalement urbain
impossible de nous quitter sans donner
la parole à notre échactiviste préféré
camilletienne est de retour et elle a
quelque chose à vous dire c'est l'heure
de sa carte verte Camille c'est à
vous la taille d'un département c'est ce
qu'on perd sous le béton tous les 10 ans
à l'heure où les sécheresses menacent
nos cultures on condamne des terres
agricoles pour des entrepos de
e-commerce on laisse des buldosers
s'accaparer les vergers pour y faire des
autoroute nos forêts denses être incisés
pour une piste de ski de plus mais les
autres qui habitent le monde ce qu'on
oublie jusqu'à ce qu'on voit des
dauphins revenir dans les canaux des
villes et des biches traverser les
passages piétons quand on était privé de
sortir confiner chez nous entre nos murs
qui maintenaient nos existences et nos
bruits à eux nos voisins pas de palier
mais de prairies que leur reste-t-il que
leur laisse-on où vont donc les oiseaux
sans arbres les seres sans forêt les
renards sans champs ils disparaissent
l'artificialisation des sols est la
première cause de la 6e extinction de
masse on les vire dehors pendant que de
l'UR dehors on en fait notre intérieur
on les congédie ailleurs sans qu'il n'y
ait plus d'ailleurs la vie se vide parce
qu'on avale son socle on construit une
terre sans terre sans se dire que la
menace est dans le titre il y a quelques
années déjà certains avaient sonné
l'alarme ils étaient 150 la fameuse
convention citoyenne sur le climat tiré
au sort on leur avait demandé de trouver
comment stopper notre course avant
l'abîme une des premières mesures
celle-ci l'article 52 de la loi qui
imposait un moratoire sur toute
structure soumise à autorisation
commerciale de plus de 10000 M Carr
artificialisant des sols concrètement ça
veut dire pause on arrête de couler le
monde sous le béton sans réfléchir et
puis nos décideurs ont rajouté une
petite Astérix en bas de la page
l'exception on arrête le monde de béton
sauf pour les entreprises privées les
entrepôts de e-commerce ont le droit eux
on arrête de construire sauf pour vous
par exemple monsieur Amazon qui fait
disparaître deux fois plus d'emplois que
vous n'en créz qui échappai à l'impôt
qui condamneit des terres cultivables
pour y empiler des flingu en plastique
ou des ordinateurs derniers CR parce que
c'est important apparemment pour tous
les Français de pouvoir recevoir chez
eux des baskets qui clignotent plus vite
que leur clinottement justement plus
important que nos champs mais
l'opposition contre ces entrepôts
s'organise partout autour de vous des
gens se soulève pour refuser ce monde de
béton celui de La Farge ou d'amazone du
man contre un entrepôt de 42000 m car à
Louail jusqu'à Colombi sogneux contre un
autre entrepôt de 160 m² en Alsace à
Belfort à fournesse à Lyon a qu'un père
à rouant rejoignez-les ils n'attendent
plus que vous alors restons attentif
autour de nous où réside encore un peu
de beauté du monde sans qu'on aille la
chercher ailleurs restons intranquille
et prêt pour refuser leur appétit
insatiable d'artificialiser ce qui se
passerait d'artifice et face à ce qu'il
reste de terre comme disait Corine Morel
d'Arle cheminer sur cette ligne de crête
qui aussi sans cesse entre inquiétude et
émerveillement et trouver nos équilibres
impliqueent une égale aptitude à déceler
la beauté à s'en réjouir et à poser un
regard lucide et déterminé sur ce qui
est en train de la saccager et
j'ajouterai en bref se battre pour elle
et en son nom une réaction peut-être oui
une réaction pour dire que ce que nous
avons essayé d'évoquer là c'est c'est
l'envie de faire plus sabre c'estàd de
faire mieux avec moi en respectant ce
qui est déjà là et je pense que c'est
s'il y a quelque chose à retenir c'est
que il faut d'abord regarder ce qu'on a
sous les pieds avant d'essayer de le
détruire pour quelque chose dont on ne
sait même pas si on en a réellement
besoin valoriser l'existant donc pour
résumer tout à fait j'ai envie de
rebondir sur la beauté du monde c'est
finalement avec le reportage de Lina
aussi sur le la zone pavillonnaire moche
alors que il y a le plus beau village de
France un peu plus loin comment on a
fait pour construire pendant des siècles
de manière aussi belle quelque part et
aussi patrimonial et et est-ce qu'on
c'est pas ça qu'on doit faire construire
aujourd'hui moins mais mieux plus plus
durable avec sans être frappés
d'obsolescence les lieux sont aussi
frappés d'obsolescence comme les objets
et donc c'est toute tout ce rapport là
qu'il FA inventé avec une chance
incroyable c'est l'immense patrimoine
bâti existant qui est un terrain de jeu
fabuleux pour pour toutes les
professions et pour tout le monde s
massono moi je je retiens aussi quand
même des des reportages l'usage et les
les fonctions d'un d'un d'un lieu de vie
la maison maintenant c'est en train de
devenir aussi un lieu de travail un lieu
d'éducation avec les mots les tutoriels
et cetera et c'est aussi je pense un
lieu privilégié d'apprentissage de
l'écologie ça a été extrêmement bien dit
sur la la la faune la flore immédiate
quand on vit dans un jardin euh on on
accède à tout ça mes enfants ils savent
distinguer un rouge queue d'un rouge
gorge ils ont vu leur plant tomate
sécher lors des canicules de 2020 2021
2022 2023 et ils se disent
qu'effectivement il y a un problème ça
sert à ça aussi un jardin ça sert à ça
aussi une maison c'est cette proximité
là qu'il faut aussi pouvoir promouvoir
et ne pas balayer d'un revers de main en
disant simplement qu'elle est moche
merci à à à tous les trois à tous les
quatre avant de N quitter quelques
saines recommandations de lecture pour
aller plus loin forcément euh la ville
stationnaire de Philippe biwix aux
éditions Acte Sud c'est un
indispensable le tour c'est pour vous ça
le tour des matériaux d'une maison
écologique aux éditions alternatives la
bible de la construction sobre aux
éditions du PUCA formes urbaines et
biodiversité un état des connaissances
de Morgan fégeot et objectif zan
apprendre du péri urbain et des
campagnes urbaines de Sylvain allemand
c'est en ligne c'est bien ça voilà bonne
lecture on se retrouve en 2024 d'ici là
soyez heureux
[Musique]
I